[Musica]
oggi in questo tempo sospeso in cui la
relazione è interrotta lo vediamo tutti
addirittura si arriva a raccomandare una
scarsa presenza di amici e conoscenti in
casa oggi che la reazione è interrotta
nessuno pensa a come riorganizzarla le
città non vanno ripensate solo su un
piano architettonico vanno ripensate
nella loro nella loro missione
sicuramente la competizione tra città e
avvenuta sulla capacità di attrarre
capitale umano una questione
fondamentale una direttrice di sviluppo
fondamentale è il sapere
l'università la cultura anche la vita
della cultura è interrotta gli spazi di
aggregazione sono fermi nessuno riesce
oggi a ripensarla possiamo utilizzare
questo tempo nel rivedere profondamente
il futuro delle città abbiamo assistito
negli scorsi anni all'ascesa e alla
caduta di alcune città pensiamo al
momento vissuto da milano che dopo
decenni in penombra ha saputo attraverso
la rigenerazione urbana soprattutto gli
ex opifici industriali ha saputo porsi
al centro dell'attenzione mondiale
grazie ad expo ha colto un'opportunità
di capitali umani e finanziari e l'ha
saputa mettere a valore di oggi sorge di
human tecnopolo
abbiamo bisogno di replicare questo tipo
di esperienze ogni città dovrebbe
ripensare alla propria missione da qui a
dieci venti trenta anni sicuramente
l'ambiente è una direttrice di sviluppo
lo abbiamo visto con progetti di
rimboschimento urbano ma noi dobbiamo
pensare a che cosa può essere ancora una
volta
per l'uomo è il è stata il luogo di
sviluppo della persona nella città
l'uomo si forma nella città l'uomo
incontra i propri effetti nella città lo
investe
e allora se riusciremo davvero porci
questa domanda ed andare a fondo questa
questione capiremo effettivamente che
missione le città potranno avere anche
perché c'è il rischio che
l'interconnessione tra luoghi sia messa
ancora in una fase di interruzione
abbiamo pensato per anni ha come
collegare le città solo con
infrastrutture fisiche sicuramente la
rivoluzione digitale ci permetterà di
creare autostrade di innovazione di
ripensare alcune alcune pratiche non
necessariamente resteremo in spazi
condivisi potremo dialogare da lontano
ma come cambia la nostra relazione se
quello che facciamo se le nostre
attività vengono fatte molto spesso da
remoto come si arricchiscono i progetti
come invece arrivano a perdere qualcosa
arrivano a perdere quel fattore umano
ecco quello di cui stiamo parlando
quello di cui dovremmo occuparci è il
fattore umano il fattore umano in un
tempo di separazione perché questo non è
solo un tempo sospeso e un tempo di
separazione il fattore umano deve
tornare al centro delle nostre vite
e allora si sta ripensando molto spesso
a come rigenerare alcuni luoghi stanno
succedendo dei fatti nelle nostre città
perché molti bed and breakfast sono
vuoti
molte aziende non avranno più bisogno
grazie all'implementazione dello
se di molto grandi che cosa faremo di
quel patrimonio immobiliare che cosa
faremo di tutto quello spazio potremo
restituire alla natura ma potremmo
invece portare in città soprattutto nei
centri cittadini larghe fette della
popolazione che ne sono escluse larghe
fette della popolazione che vivono
lontane dalle luci della città larghe
fette della popolazione che non trovano
le opportunità che cercano nella città
al tempo stesso però possiamo pensare
anche a luoghi più piccoli luoghi che
assicurino sicurezza in termini di
salute e anche in termini di qualità di
vita
ripensare gli spazi deve essere una
sfida che dobbiamo porci assolutamente
altrimenti non ricaveremo valore da
questo tempo sospeso i mesi che abbiamo
di fronte sono mesi difficili sono mesi
che ci chiamano a nuove abitudini non
sappiamo ancora come reagiremo se se non
ci sarà lo scrivono tutti un nuovo
lockdown queste nuove pratiche queste
nuove abitudini in c incideranno
profondamente sulle nostre personalità
personalità che sono abituati allo
scambio all'incontro l'interdizione
dell'incontro fa venir meno anche una
capacità produttiva dell'essere umano e
in definitiva non può esserci una
rinuncia alla centralità dell'uomo
quale che sia la rivoluzione digitale
quale che sia il mondo che progettiamo
se al centro non metteremo l'uomo non
saremo in grado di fare nulla ecco
perché un'altra esperienza utile può
essere quella dello scambio di
di esperienze rispetto a questo tempo
nei luoghi in luoghi distinti
il virus ha un impatto diverso a seconda
delle città noi abbiamo bisogno di
organizzare dei dati abbiamo bisogno di
big data alla fine di questa esperienza
ma anche durante per capire il perché
dell'impatto diverso il perché di alcune
conseguenze diverse da lì dovremo
costruire dei protocolli sanitari che
possano poi invece garantire una
resistenza a future pandemie perché
potrebbe essere potrebbe non essere
un'esperienza isolata ma abbiamo bisogno
di fare quello che abbiamo sempre fatto
di condividere questa è stata sinora
l'epoca della condivisione dello sharing
dello scambio non deve cessare di
esserlo ma non può esserlo solo su una
infrastruttura digitale deve esserlo
fisicamente
ecco perché dobbiamo anche pensare ad
una nuova alleanza tra le città dobbiamo
pensare ad un nuovo scambio le città non
devono rinchiudersi tra mura
sebbene le misure restrittive a volte lo
impongano noi dobbiamo riaprire le città
a all'interlocuzione al confronto e sono
state le città anche il motore della
crescita europea
pensate ad un'esperienza come l'erasmus
alla competizione tra città per attrarre
capitale umano capitale giovane pensiamo
a quanto abbia impattato un'esperienza
del genere nel cammino verso la crescita
di alcune relazioni che erano in ritardo
come come la spagna pensate da queste
esperienze di scambio che devono essere
alimentata ecco noi dobbiamo ripensare
tutto ciò dobbiamo pensare già ora
sebbene la primavera sia distante e
prima
prima di marzo prima della prossima
primavera si è difficile immaginare una
copertura con il bacino di larga fetta
della popolazione e che permetta di
uscire da questo da questa pandemia che
però è anche un freno psicologico
noi non dobbiamo cedere a questa visione
di chiusura soprattutto sul piano
psicologico non dobbiamo far sì che
l'incontro sia una rinuncia non dobbiamo
rinunciare all'incontro in definitiva
per concludere il dibattito pubblico ha
bisogno di essere animato da questi temi
la città è il luogo o è stata molto
spesso luogo di incontro pensiamo ai
caffè di incontro di idee nelle città
sono cresciute idee e movimenti e allora
recita non possono abdicare a questa
missione non possono applicare a questa
missione e soprattutto devono ripensare
la propria identità noi immaginiamo un
tempo in cui la fuoriuscita di capitale
umano dalle città a può garantirci
progresso
dobbiamo chiederci lo è soprattutto
iniziare ad organizzare una vera e
propria politica industriale che non
investa solo la mobilità sostenibile
le fonti di approvvigionamento
energetico ma si occupi anzitutto di
capitale umano informazione e di e di
attrazione di opportunità le città hanno
un identità ciascuna ha un'identità
soprattutto in italia
e allora ci vuole una competizione
virtuosa che parta da questo e
riproponga non solo il nostro paese ma
l'europa che più di altri ha
a dispone di città con un profondo senso
e significato storico l'europa e
l'italia possono proiettarsi in avanti
se sapranno investire questo tempo nella
progettazione se sapranno costruire una
visione per le proprie città
[Musica]